be your own biggest cheerleader and i
think that
stems from having that belief it's so
important to believe in yourself and
have that confidence
um because as soon as you start
questioning things i think that's just
when
certainly in the early days you can
start doubting everything
and somebody with tenacity again i think
is
is really essential you've got to kind
of have that winning mentality
um and really sort of go after it said
belief unity loyalty and honesty but the
four really key things and i think that
really
does say a lot about um if you're coming
into recruitment you kind of need to
have those values behind you three best
bits of advice for someone that
is sort of early on that leadership
career make them aware of your
expectations early on
you know explain to them how you work to
take time out
to make sure that they're not sort of
suffering in silence
take them outside of the business um you
know find out what their motivators are
find out what their whys are um so
george was was seven
uh and then chloe came along in 2007 so
i returned back to work when the economy
crashed
it was just the worst time uh
i thought i'd lost it i thought yeah i
thought i've
i've absolutely lost the knack of how to
do this i really
really respect um my director tenisha's
attitude where we've got to battle
through we've got to carry on here
[Music]